[Music]
i was at a birthday party for a
seven-year-old
i let the parents complain that video
games are too violent but what the hell
is the pinata
4c hill 2004
created them for mature
to get their kids into like a mini mob
frenzy swing a little baby horse over
tree getting weapons
freaking out like died
which has to be a weird moment
for the family dog
just walking around
is this one they have planned
gotta tell the
[Laughter]
because others why they go crazy because
the horse is full of candy right
which i don't think is a good lesson
to be teaching children
that animals are full of candy
so if i ever have a kitty birthday party
i'm gonna get a pinata
and i'm gonna fill it with like
like giblets
[Laughter]
i know it's gross but just for that
moment where susie q sunshine
give that final blow in her birthday
dress like
[Applause]
one of the three most confused
lungs are flat
happy birthday
crying
confusion
but then learn
that's a horse
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you